a hundred billion company this is a
pretty exciting time for
entrepreneurship you're at that point in
your stage like this gets important the
cost of failure of starting a business
today is by far the lowest has ever been
business advice to Harley 10 years ago
you got one thing you can
tell welcome everybody to the game I got
a special episode for you guys today as
you know I do not have many guests on my
podcast I don't like sharing the
spotlight um so if somebody's going to
be on they've got to be really really
special
and have true expertise uh to give and I
think uh the person that I have with me
today or that will be joining us today
definitely meets that in Spades and so
Harley is uh a god amongst men a legend
in in the making and uh runs a a small
company you may not have heard of it uh
Shopify uh which right now is a publicly
traded company it's worth right now I
think it was 80 billion uh if I'm not
mistaken harly correct me there closer
to closer to 100 billion but yeah that
was 20 billion off you you just ramed it
down by 2020 billion which for someone
like me like you know this is like I
don't come from this world this is you
know I'm I'm a tourist here uh that's a
lot of money so a hundred billion doll
company so that's uh so 10 10 figures is
a billion 11 12 a 12 fig company there
you go um and just uh the only thing
that Rivals the the business success
that he has is just the humility uh that
he brings to it he was willing to hop on
a call with me uh before this and uh we
hit it off and uh I was like I just I
know my audience would love to talk to
you uh and and just kind of hear your
perspective of Entrepreneurship and you
have such an interesting story that I
think will relate to so many people in
my audience from the people who are just
trying to figure out what they want to
do uh to make money all the way to you
know right now 20% of my audience is uh
you know winning entrepreneurs with you
know large companies and and so forth so
we definitely have the gamut from an
entrepreneurship perspective kind of
beginning middle and end and um yeah so
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us today it's a great honor to be
here Alex thank you so much I'm a big
fan of the Pod and I think what you're
doing is making Business and
Entrepreneurship um I mean very similar
to the Mion Chava you're making it more
accessible and I think that is the
coolest thing in the world this idea
that business was out of touch for most
people both financially from a capital
perspective or because of knowledge and
insight and experience I think those
days are long over and I think we were
going through an entrepreneurial
Renaissance right now and I think people
like you and and your your community uh
is leading the way on in that front well
I appreciate it and I mean everything
that we do is um just for everybody on
the Pod is I know Harley and I agree on
this um is to just try and break down as
many barriers between where people are
and where they want to be right A lot of
people have this vision for their lives
they want and there are things that get
in their way some of them are between
your ears some of them are between your
hands and keyboard and so Shopify has
taken a lot of that between hands and
keyboard out of the way to decrease the
friction of actually getting a product
launch get it online actually get
customers you can do it from anywhere in
the world which is uh again something
that 30 years ago just wasn't really a
thing and now everyone can have access
to this Stu so um I'm gonna go I'm gonna
kind of break this uh po into three kind
of sections Loosely uh so first kind of
Chunk I want to talk about looking back
and I think that'll that'll relate to a
lot of people who are listening or
watching right now kind of like Zero to
Hero like what what got you to hear and
all the things that that that come with
that uh Second chunk will go over what's
hero to to superhero right like what is
what's the for what's forward look like
what's the future look what do you see
um and I'll dive into some more you know
specific details around that stuff and
then at the very end we'll go kind of
like final nuggets and wrapping it up of
of like forward and backwards what are
kind of like the principles and truths
that um that you would try and pass on
to the people who are listening cool it
let's do it all right that's our road
map so I know a little bit about the
story but my audience doesn't um so you
have this really unique thing of being
employee W and customer one can you walk
us through like just the beginning of
shop like even the decision to jump into
Shopify what what the risks that were
associated with that what was life prior
to that and then like what what were the
this the the factors that got you into
that um step one because I think that's
where a lot of people are right now yeah
uh so I was born in Montreal I was born
in Canada uh I moved to South Florida
with my parents and my sisters when I
was very young uh I was always
entrepreneurial my parents did not have
a lot of money
um but my father to his credit uh my
dad's an immigrant he came to Canada
from Hungary in the revolution my
grandparents are Holocaust Survivors I
mean we are you know we were we were
poor immigrants um and although my dad
never had much money to give me because
I always had these little silly business
ideas when I was a kid what my dad did
for me which was very valuable was even
like when I was like 10 years old every
silly business idea that I had he would
validate it by actually making me these
business cards that would say the name
of the business and my name on it and
I'm now a dad I have two daughters
Bailey and Zoe who are five and seven
and now that I think about parenting and
stuff I'm I'm like I think a lot more
about that that story and those stories
of my father making those business cards
because at the time it didn't seem that
profound and in hindsite now as you know
a father myself I realized these small
things that we do for our kids have this
massive impact and so even though these
businesses were all very silly you know
uh trading like trading cards and
lemonade stands and eventually a DJ
business when I was 13 years old I was
always an entrepreneurial kid and
partially was because I thought
entrepreneurship was this fun activity
like I I wasn't really into sports
playing them or watching them uh I
wasn't really into video games I was
kind of into like this idea of like you
know selling something and that was
always fun for me uh moved to South
Florida went uh finished high school
there and moved back to Canada when I
was 17 in 2001 to go to Mill University
uh Migel is in Montreal where where I
live now I went to Miguel because it was
cheap my parents didn't have much money
and so because because I was born in
Canada I kind of got this like instate
tuition thing unfortunately very quickly
uh once I moved to uh to Montreal to
sort of Migel my dad got into some
trouble and our family lost everything
and once again I sort of you know pulled
out this tool that I'd been tinkering
with throughout my life called
entrepreneurship um to to make some
money I started t-shirt business when I
was at Miguel made t-shirts for a bunch
of universities across Canada like the
promotional t-shirts you got the first
day of school fro Frost or orientation
uh stuff and I loved it it was great I
wasn't necessarily passionate about
t-shirts but I love this sort of idea of
of of been a being able to support
myself and and help my my family I was
really can i h on this real quick
because I think absolutely jump in
anywhere you want yeah the the point
that Harley just made I just want to
underline which is that the first
business he had one I don't think that
you thought this was going to be the
business I will have for the rest of my
life this is my dream this is my vision
you were trying to make money right
that's all is um
and I think a lot of uh people who are
aspiring are trying to find this like
perfect puzzle piece that's going to fit
all of these things it's going to be my
passion it's can be fulfilling it can be
the next Amazon when a lot of times I
think it's a big fallacy because the
first business just gives you a little
bit of like to show you what the next
step to take is because you learn a
bunch of stuff from that first business
that's right and so I just want to just
take the pause for the audience that
everyone's like I got to find the
perfect thing when promo shirts for
freshman and sophomores it glamorous
right it's it's it's not glamorous and
in fact the only unfair advantage that I
had was that I was selling T-shirts to a
customer who was who I also was part of
that demographic meaning like I was
selling T-shirts to the student council
treasurer or procurement office so they
can give them out to students and I
myself was a student and so the pitch
that I made was that one I very low
overhead because it's just me I was I
was the CEO and the janitor I was I was
printing t-shirts myself uh so one I'm
going to be cheaper two I'm going to
care a lot because I really need this to
work and three I'm going to make
t-shirts for people like me and so I I
kind of know what your students want
because I myself and one of your
students um just to go step back because
I you said was super interesting so I
sort of skipped over this but when I was
13 years old the the business that
really got start like started me an
entrepreneurship a real business was
again I was 13 so uh you know uh I
wouldn't put too much you know uh
Credence on the fact that it was a real
business but it was a real thing was I
wanted to be a DJ I was I'm Jewish I
went to a lot of bar mitzvah when I was
13 years old and I thought the DJs were
the coolest people in the world they
were sort of magicians in my mind they
would take a group of people that were
sitting down eating some rubber chicken
dinner in some Hotel ballroom and like
three minutes later using their voice
and using lighting and and music there'
be a conga line I just thought they were
just they were like magicians I called
around a bunch of DJ companies to ask
them if they would hire me and of course
they said no because I was 13 had no
experience and and didn't know how to DJ
um but because I had this sort of you
know like silly confidence that that
these business cards had provided for me
I had this idea to start my own DJ
company and hire myself so that was sort
of when this idea of Entrepreneurship as
a tool to solve problems was sort of
cemented in my in my very you know
immature young brain and then when I
needed to make money again at 17 I was
an undergrad in college I once again I
didn't even think about you know I
should go get a job somewhere
immediately my thought was all right I
got to start another business to make
some money here so it began I I began to
form this what what is now effectively
my I think it's shopify's Mission it's
also my personal mission which is an
entrepreneurship is this incredibly
powerful tool because it's Democratic
and it allows anyone and anybody around
to start something with very little and
doesn't matter who you are what your
last name is and and who your parents
are my parents were nobody's it matters
how much value you add and so I ran this
t-shir business all throughout college
and developed a really good set of
mentors along the way people that I sort
of met and some people were lawyers and
others were these random entrepreneurs
and you know Dove Charney from American
Apparel now he's sort of I guess
disgraced but at the time he was a very
big deal uh starting American Apparel he
was another Jewish entrepreneur from
Montreal and I met these people along
the way and one of those Entre one of
those mentors convinced me uh to when I
finished college to go to law school not
to become a lawyer but rather to become
a better entrepreneur almost like
finishing school for entrepreneurship
and I was uh incredibly impressionable I
was 21 when I was finishing College
again I had a little bit of money from
the t-shirts but not much and he said
look I'm going to teach law next year at
the University of Ottawa which is the
capital of Canada why don't you come to
Ottawa go to go to law school here I'll
be in town I can sort of help you
navigate the city um and and you'll go
to law school not with the mandate to to
to get called to the bar or ever
litigate or practice law but rather as a
way to accumulate more skills that will
be very valuable as you think about
scaling a business longer term and so
was 2005 moved to Ottawa no friends no
family there um and by this point
entrepreneurship was a part of my you my
identity and so like I always did when I
moved to a new place I I asked where the
entrepreneurs hung out and very very
fortunately very luckily I was directed
to a coffee shop and I was told that
there's a group of entrepreneurs that
hung out at this coffee shop every
Friday evening and they called
themselves the young entrepreneurs Club
the YC and um I started showing up there
every Friday and meeting these young
entrepreneurs and one of those
entrepreneurs was This brilliant
programmer uh named Toby who had just
moved to Canada I think couple about a
year earlier from Germany and he moved
to Canada because he met a girl and he
wanted to go be close to that girl her
name is as all people move for that
reason very good very good reason love
is always a good reason to move
somewhere uh and Toby had moved to
Canada from Germany didn't have papers
to work and so he was told that even as
a new immigrant he could start a
business and being in Canada where it's
very cold a lot of snow he loves
snowboarding he decided he wanted to
build a snowboard shop on the internet
in 2005 there were two ways to sell a
product on the Internet the first way
was to sell through a Marketplace at the
time like eBay was really the more the
most prominent one uh Amazon I don't
think at the time alive for third-party
sellers it was still a first-party
Marketplace so You' eBay and you had a
bunch of these sort of very nichy
marketplaces but eBay being the big one
so you could sell on a Marketplace or
you would pay a company like IBM they
had websphere or Oracle or at or um or
sap all these big Enterprise companies
had some sort of e-commerce
functionality for very large Enterprises
for like Walmart yeah uh and and that
would be like a couple million bucks and
Toby did not like the idea of of renting
customers from a Marketplace and he did
not like the idea of well he didn't have
a million dollars to spend on on
Enterprise software so that was
impossible so he wrote this piece of
software um using Ruby on Rails where he
was a sort of core developer of Ruby on
Rails nearly days with dhh and a bunch
of really interesting people and he
wrote this piece of ser to sell his
snowboards and that's around the time
where I met him he was like just you
selling these snowboards and it was it
was a really neat little business he was
making real money and around that and
and and again I was I'm in law school
now and so I'd ask him if I can use um
the software uh to sell my own my own
products which in my case would be
t-shirts and by that point he had
already sort of figured out that the
snowboard business was a good idea but
the software that he had written uh to
sell these snowboards was a great great
idea and uh and and shortly thereafter I
ended up uh building a store on Shopify
this is 2006 at the time and I became
one of the first people to use what
would become uh at the time it was
called jaded pixel it wasn't actually
called Shopify originally um and I would
be one of the first people to use the
software and I built this I I ran this
t-shirt business as direct to Consumer
licensed t-shirt business all throughout
uh law school and um and that was sort
of my first entry into into Shopify
meeting Toby and then when I finished uh
finished La grad school um I called Toby
and said look like I love
entrepreneurship it's it's everything I
I think it's it's the greatest thing for
me it's my passion my hobby I wanted I
want to increase the surface area for
more people and honestly what I experien
building a beautiful scalable store
sitting in my tax law class on Shopify
um I think more people should experience
that and um and I joined him about a
year later in in 2009 or so uh and I was
like the first engineer to join the
company uh and uh and it was amazing it
was one of the greatest I mean I just it
was I have really fond memories of those
very early days but that's uh long
answer short a question of how I got the
Shopify no this is perfect because
that's this is a great pause point
because there I was writing down some
notes just for the audience um and then
I want to definitely we're going to go
from like okay you're now in Shopify and
what are trials and tribulations because
of course I'm sure going from that to
100 billion was probably just straight
line very smooth sailing you haven't had
any issue
um and I'm sure everyone will be glad to
hear that very short story but we'll get
to that one um but just everyone who's
listening number one um the first
business that Harley started was just
for money and it wasn't just some
magical thing that was going to be
perfect he did what he had to do and he
learned a ton of skills that really
valuable along the way second thing is
that uh and I want to emphasize this is
people a lot of times are like man I
don't know what to sell or what business
should I start and I think the easiest
one to use is just solve your own
problem scratch your own edch totally
like almost every business I've had
well every every really good business
I've had has come from that which is
like like I mean even the the the
furthest one we have now because not
comom a family office and I wish I had
had this available to me when I was
scaling up our companies like somebody
who'd already been there sold multiple
times and like had a vested interest Etc
um but scratching your own itch um also
I want to highlight some people kind of
get segmented in one thing or the other
like you did a physical products
business but earlier you done a DJ thing
even though it was not you know you made
money so you made a profit and so like
in my mind like self-employed whatever
like it was a service based business so
you had a service business and you also
had a physical product bus so you were
flexible in terms of how you were
willing to make money and I wasn I was
agnostic to what I was selling I mean to
your point you know I I I think one of
the easiest ways to figure out what to
sell you you know you said scratch your
own itch another way to do it is simply
just to like tell a bunch of people that
you're thinking of starting a business
and just leave it out in The Ether the
reason that I started selling T-shirts
to universities was as I told people
that my dad wasn't around anymore mom
had no money I needed to make some money
I need to start a business the more
people people I I spoke to about that a
lot of the ideas that I got were dumb
but but more and more people started
telling me hey what about this hey what
about that most of the things that they
mentioned were not great ideas but then
someone randomly his name is Jamie once
told told me remember this like day
perfectly clear he said hey just so you
know Migel spends
$25,000 a semester on uh on t-shirts on
printed Li on printed promotional
t-shirts it turned out he was wrong
these universities spent a quarter
million dollars be way harder than that
right but because I was putting it out
there this thing that I was looking sort
of business a bunch of people sort of
became almost like um my my my idea
generation machine and so this whole
idea that like I know there's there's a
lot out there about like don't tell
people your goals and and and and keep
things to yourself I I call I
think do things and tell people is super
important even at the early stages of
starting these things well I'm a big I
mean my second book $100 million leads
uh advertising is the process of making
known and so if no one knows about your
stuff no one can buy it they must first
know about it in order to buy it and so
if you just think about it from a first
principal's
perspective ain't no customers if they
don't know uh so first way to do that so
two things that I also want to highlight
so you talked about two different types
of people that you surround yourself
with one was mentors so just for
everyone in my audience we're talking
people ahead right and then the other
thing was the community of peers right
he had the coffee shop where you met
Toby who ultimately you know got got you
into this thing again by chance but both
of those thing increase your luck
surface area the amount of different
potential opportunities for exposing
opportunity well yeah and so um I just
want to highlight that because a lot of
people feel like entrepreneurship is
lonely and it can be but to a degree it
is a choice right and if you can't
physically move environments uh you can
do it online now and that wasn't
available back then but now we've got
online communities we've got school
we've got you know all these things
where people can connect um and when I
say School SK o.com school um people can
actually connect and meet one another
all right now uh the last one is
resourcefulness and this kind of ties
well to kind of the next the next
chapter of this journey which is that
like you did all this stuff like
you Toby wrote code so that he could so
he could sell his snowboards right like
it's there's just there's a there's this
whole like everything of course our
whole mission is to make things easier
make things more accessible to people
but on some level like it's the fact
that it becomes difficult is what makes
the goal worthwhile right and if if
everyone could do it then one would do
it and then it would no longer be worthy
right everyone can tie their shoes
everyone can get dressed and so no one's
like congratulations there's this whole
um I think Chris Rock's kit where he's
like what do you want a cookie he's like
man I ain't never been prison he's like
you ain't supposed to go to jail right
and he goes this whole thing and so
right now like the fact that it's
difficult is just another barrier that
somebody you might have to compete with
will have to go over and so it gives
yourself a little stripe that you can um
show yourself about who you really are
all right also remember remember this if
you kind to think about like if you kind
of um go back to I don't know go back
200 years and you think about starting a
business um the one thing that besides
Capital to get started and knowledge and
understanding and Technology to help you
do it forget all that stuff for a second
one of the big risks of starting a
business historically was that the cost
of failure could affect your life in a
very adverse way meaning um when my
grandfather came to North America from
Eastern Europe he started an egg
business he had a little egg stall at at
at a local farmers market which actually
still stands today my uncle currently
run runs it um but he had to take a loan
out on his home in order to afford the
the fee and the the cost of actually
renting this particular stall if this
did not work the result of that would be
no food on the table no roof over their
head and that is that is effectively how
businesses were built so that people
with more Capital were able to take more
risks people that had more Capital were
able to invest more uh people that had
more Capital were able to have you know
be able to mitigate the cost of failure
well one thing that has changed
dramatically and I would say today like
literally right now Alex you and I are
talking about this the cost of failure
of starting a business today is by far
the lowest it's ever been whether you
use a product like Shopify or use
whatever you decide to do the cost of
failure is effectively $39 if it works
you scale it um literally like three
feet from me I have um was a gift um
from Ben Francis who's the founder of
gym shark and it's a Christmas gift he
gave a holiday gift he gave me it's the
original screen print from the original
jimm shark uh the first t-shirt he made
it was it was Ben's been a big part of
my life and I've been I think a big part
of his life and so his gift was the
original screen that created the first
t-shirt uh for Jim shark when Ben
started it was 2012 out of his dorm room
if it would have gone if it would have
failed he would have gone back to class
I mean he was literally also delivering
pizzas I think for Pizza Hut at the time
if I get that right or some some pizza
company but if it worked he would go on
to build a multi-billion dollar company
called gym shark so think about that the
upside and that was 2012 that was like
you know 12 years ago the upside today
of starting a business is effectively
infinite growth if you do it well and
you're smart and you're adding Great
Value the down side is a couple less
cups of coffee or a couple less
Starbucks uh for that week that is
remarkable and I think that um I mean if
there's anything that like there's one
underlying Point here it's the um it's
risky adusted return right is that
everyone here now can get endless shots
on go right now because of how
accessible entrepreneurship is you
basically just keep taking lottery
tickets and if you lose then you just
buy another scratch off right and you
try it again and so you still have the
upside except the thing is is it's not
rigged for you to lose like there
actually is a lot of people who want you
to win and there's an entire economy
around you um well not just that right
now what that's created is nearly a
quarter 25% of us consumers in 2024 are
considering starting a business that's
the highest I believe it's ever been
number two is since 2021 there's been
15.5 million new business applications
in the US an 85% increase from 2004 to
2021 the White House put out a bunch of
stats on this recently I mean that is
the reason that it's happening is not
just because technolog is getting better
and not just because of great podcast
like like and content like you're
putting out there it's because people
are realizing that entrepreneurship may
be the vehicle for them to actually find
their life's work make their life better
create Independence like do the thing
that they love most this is a pretty
exciting time for entrepreneurship and I
think the cost of failure thing is a big
part of
it so now you're employee number one non
non-developer employee number one you've
you've used the product you fell in love
with it and this is now aligned with
your calling so walk me through kind of
the the stages of growth and I'll if you
can give kind of like internal external
so this is what was happening externally
Maybe Revenue levels customer levels
things like that and then mirrored what
does that look like internally so I'm
shifting a little bit towards my my
business owners right now all right so
now we're talking like okay we've got
the business we're we're generating
Revenue are is it cash flow positive do
they have investor like how how what's
yeah just give me the the scoop so we
were bootstrapped um we had um a very
very small angel investor um in early on
which um his name is John um he's he's
now a multi-billionaire I believe um and
so is his wife
uh separately because she also put some
money in but it was a very small amount
of money we were bootstrap we were
profitable um and we we when I joined we
didn't have a CFO we didn't have a CMO I
mean part of what I viewed my role as
and anyone who's listening who was
joining a very early stage company uh as
a non-engineer like the person not
running you know writing code um or or
Building
Product the the role that I wanted to
that I felt I should play and that I I
think I did play was this Swiss army
knife let me figure out everything and
anything that is going to be valuable to
the people that are writing code and
whether that's commercialization or
sales or support or I mean literally
figuring out like where we're going to
like work at of like like figure
negotiating the lease uh for it or um
figuring out you know what are we who
are we paying for I think we were paying
Rackspace at the time like negotiating a
Rackspace contract I think at the time
we only had one payment integration
which was the PayPal negotiating the
PayPal rev share in those very early
days this sort of Swiss army knife type
model I think was really really
important because I mean the the you can
be the greatest salesperson or marketer
in the world if you have a great product
matched with a great ability to sell and
commercialize that's where this thing
gets really interesting and I deeply
believe that Shopify even back you know
in 2010 had this incredible product
Leaps and Bounds uh better than all the
competition the competition at the time
was like Yahoo stores or a couple other
like that but very very few competitors
and so this idea of being a Swiss army
knife was important and that's what I
did I you know if there was an
opportunity for me to tell the story
publicly um to a local newspaper in in
Ottawa Canada I would take that
opportunity if there was an opportunity
for me to help someone get a job done
internally I would take that opportunity
but that Swiss army knife was that that
sort of model of that was very very help
helpful and as part of that um I think I
earned the trust of of Toby in
particular but but also you know the
other engineers because I was just there
to add value that's it in fact um i' I'd
actually been called to the bar and so I
think my like I was I was also the
company's lawyer and again I I've been
out of law school for all of 10 months I
think at that point but whatever I could
do I was going to do that and it was
only a couple years later we we raised
our series a about a year later I think
it was a $7 million uh investment from
besser who L it um on a $25 million I
think post um and then and that's really
when we began to realize that okay there
is a real there there that this company
could be something remarkable large
scalable and we can really make it dent
on at the time it was really we were
focused on smbs and e-commerce only very
different than today where we do
business of all sizes and Retail
everywhere but it was smbs and and and
it was it was e-commerce only and it was
only until you know after our series B
and C that we began really figuring out
like okay what what are each other's
superpowers and and this idea of rather
than all of us become these sort of
well-rounded objects these sort of
riverstones what if we all were very
precise on the thing that we think we
could be the best in the world at and
spend our time level did you start doing
that so if we're walking through this
because right now probably around
probably like around series b or series
C we began we hired a CFO we hired a CMO
we hired a had of sales it was around
that time where we felt we were well
capitalized I think our our series B was
about 100100 million valuation uh this
is like 2013 or so around that
time don't uh have no mean yeah I'm not
sure a lot less than than $100 million
many employees were around then just I'm
just trying to give uh probably uh
probably 50 to 100 at that point okay
yeah yeah okay got it so like small
midsize got it okay cool um and and a
lot of what we were trying to do then is
like find you know find at least a lot
how I spend my time was find new
channels so this idea that okay we can
only sell so many people on Shopify but
there's this ma massive EOS system of
web agencies and Freelancers and
developers who are in Oklahoma and are
in you know uh places like South America
and they're in Singapore and they're in
Vancouver and they're in you know New
Mexico and what if we actually created
something whereby if someone walked in
to their agency to their business and
said I need an online store what could
we do to actually make it so that they
would say by default great we'll build
it on Shopify that's sort of on the
referral side on the product side
another thing that was really um that we
created around that time was the shopy
app store which I believe today is one
of the largest ecosystems of thirdparty
developers on the planet I mean if you
are building an app for Commerce today
the best most effective goom Market
strategy is to put in the shopy app
store because you have millions of of
customers free applications that that
now seems you know polished and and a
really healthy kind of flywheel of an
ecosystem but originally the reason that
the app stores really set up was all
these different Merchants were coming to
us and they all had a very unique and
and a very particular business and so we
really focused on let's make Shopify
core offering what most people need most
of the time checkout payments inventory
marketing anal analytics let's make that
like world class but everything that is
very specific to a particular Merchants
business let's invite third parties from
all over the world to build apps on top
of it which meant that no matter what
the particular needs of your business
might be you would find 100% product
Market fit using Shopify because of this
op ecosystem and we didn't have to build
everything ourself which would have been
impossible and so some of these things
now in hindsight seem like wow shop
ecosystem is really cool and the App
Store is is is is is humming but
originally it was done because we
couldn't build every feature oursel nor
nor should we so what what were some of
the like absolute key decisions or like
business principles that you learned
kind of scaling through this um focus
was really important not being
everything to everyone I mean today you
know um like last week was was the
national retail federation's Big Show
literally like the most important
conference in Enterprise retail um and I
I sit on the board now of NRF with like
the likes of the CEO of of you know
Brian from Target and John from Walmart
and like you know these amazing people
like that that run effectively all all
of retail uh in all over the world and
so now we're really obviously you know
getting some of the biggest retailers
who Shopify but there was absolutely no
way we were even considering that in
those days because fundamentally we
wanted to win our particular Market
which was
smbs in in English-speaking countries uh
they wanted to sell on the internet and
so one thing that was really valuable
was like Focus don't sort of and a lot
of our competitors by the way ended up
going out of business because they kind
of ran up Market way too soon and they
left the entire base of smbs um
available um they didn't like the idea
that smbs you know some churn and not
every business succeeds and we thought
well what if we just slightly increased
the Chan of success and mitigated the
risk if every single person thinking
about starting a business like in the in
the shower in the morning then did so
with Shopify even though not all will
succeed as long as the ones that do stay
with us indefinitely they will offset
the cost of ones that leave and so one
was really making sure we were very very
focused the second thing that was really
important to us I think was that the
product was super simple and you know
now companies like I don't know Mar or
or Mattel or Staples or you know uh uh
glossier uh Alo yoga view all these
amazing Brands all you Shopify skims
like and what's neat even today about
Shopify is that the complexity of the
product almost reveals itself over time
rather than simply being inated with
every single feature and functionality
Shopify can be used by someone just
setting up a store at their mom's
kitchen table it also can be used by
Trina who runs figs which is a publicly
traded company uh they make uniform
scrubs uniform scrubs uh hospital scrubs
and and the fact that the same codebase
can make those things was something that
was always important keep it really
really simple and credit to Toby and his
sort of vision around product because
that's really what he he drilled in all
of us was that the product has to be
incredibly simple so first is focus
second is Simplicity and the third one
was we really tried to run a really
tight business meaning we knew what our
sort of CA to LTV ratio is so cost to
customer acquisition on one side versus
lifetime value and as long I don't know
if if you're I want to make sure I
Define all the acronyms um my okay okay
so we knew what our cact LTV ratio was
and once we got it above one effectively
it meant that okay now it's time to go
raise money because the more dollars we
put on the left side the more dollar 80s
or whatever the ratio was we got on on
on the right side and so by being
meticulous and thoughtful about that um
I think it was really helpful maybe the
last thing I'll say which seems a little
bit soft but it's important to say we
were really really like patient meaning
we want like even today we want to build
a 100-year business we're now about 20
years into it we had 80 years left to go
but even then when we were you know five
eight 10 years in we still thought about
this like really long-term business
focused which meant that we were not
willing to pull forward future profits
at a discount like pretty much most of
our competitors I think were doing at
that point so what were what were some
of the key growth kind of levers that
you were able to pull throughout this
process that like really accelerated
like if you had to name the three
biggest things in the first 10 years of
Shopify that like man if we hadn't done
this we wouldn't have been able to get
to the next level I mean I think the App
Store the ecosystem is really important
both on making sure the product had a
prod had 100% product Market fit um and
also in the referral so I think that was
really important because it meant that
we had a we had effectively uh a
distributed Salesforce that wasn't on
our payroll and just something small on
that that really matters I remember at
the time the Apple iOS store had uh an
8020 rev share split so if you built
something um on um on app excuse me it
had a 7030 revshare split so you buil
something on Apple you as a developer
keep 70% 30% goes to Apple and I
remember when we were talking about our
rev share for our app store we actually
said 8020 not that we were competing
with the Apple the iOS store I mean we
were we were a small little nothing
company in Canada but this idea that we
would be more generous than the
incumbents might be was very important
and the truth is the additional 10 10
points didn't really change it for us
but it just meant that when you built on
Shopify you deeply understood that you
were going to get a very fair and a
generous rev share split that was one I
think the second one uh we we really
hammered hard was this thing called um
the build of business competition it was
like our big aha moment uh and it was
you know we we had an article in New
York Times about it but it started in a
very kind of simple way um we had met
Tim Ferris I think in 2009 or so and he
became an adviser and Tim is now a very
good friend to both my me and Toby And
and we've done his pod he's a great guy
but Tim looked at Shopify and
said great product you guys are missing
something most people even though your
product is great easy to use and you're
making entrepreneurship more accessible
most people have a risk adversion to
some entrepreneurship for one of two
reasons either too expensive or they
don't know how to use it and he had this
idea that we should create a competition
whereby someone would start a brand new
business on Shopify um like Jan one and
six months later the store with the
highest sales would win I think we said
$110,000 and then Tim said it's got to
be 100,000 we did not have $100,000 to
give out that way but our Hope was that
by the time the competition ended we
would actually have that type of money
and we launched the the the first build
of business competition uh in 201 10 um
and it got us you know I think the
article in the New York Times I have to
go check but I'm sure your listeners
will keep me honest here but I think
it's like a startup starts their own
startup competition like launches their
own startup comp it was because it was
kind of a silly thing that we ourselves
were starting competition the winner
that year was a company called dodo case
that made these beautiful um uh
beautiful leather iPad cases it was the
year the iPad was coming out and so that
was one of those ways where if you sort
of read sort of the Jeffrey Moore uh I
think it's Jeffrey Moore cross in the
chasm book where he talks about you know
technology adoption Cycles go from early
adopters to mainstream it felt like the
build the business competition helped us
cross the chasm from early adopters to
the mainstream and and over over I think
we did the build the business
competition for like five years after
that and ultimately the stores were
getting like Jim shark won one year uh
and and like some Nick swear won one
year like these big companies ended up
winning uh but so we couldn't give out
100,000 anymore so we had to come with
these new ideas like how do we
incentivize the creation new businesses
and we did things like the winner would
spend a week with Richard Branson on
Necker Island and the winner would go
and spend like go have lunch with Seth
Goden and so we created this really cool
stuff but I would say that's probably
the second sort of Vector in terms of
growth we found a way for us to cross
the gasm I just want I'll pause right
there we I'm a huge fan of the the build
of business competition and oh you know
about it oh cool yeah yeah yeah super
super well acquainted with it oh that's
so bring it up yeah that that was I mean
that like that was something that was
really really important maybe the third
thing that I think was probably um
really valuable was we began to look at
what are the other things like what is
the relationship that our product has in
the lives of people that use it and the
relationship started to look like when
someone said they were going to work in
the morning what they meant was they
were opening up their Shi admin on their
laptop or on their on their desktop so
if we were becoming the center of like
their day-to-day work where they added
products and fulfilled orders and added
new SKS and and ran marketing campaigns
um what else can we do to be valuable to
be helpful there one thing that most
people don't realize today uh which is
the case I'll bring it back in a second
is that if you were to pretend today
that Shopify was a single retailer like
if you were to aggregate all our stores
just in the us alone we would be the
second largest online retailer in
America after Amazon okay why is it
important because if you were the second
largest online retailer in America and
you go to negotiate rates with payment
gateways and shipping companies and
Banks and all these different types of
andary Services the economy of scale
that you have is so massive well even in
the early days back going back I know
say 2013 2014 or so as we were thinking
about adding new features new
functionality we call Merchant Solutions
we began to think about in that way
whereby could we go and negotiate the
best rates from from the payment
gateways as if we were the second
largest retailer we weren't second we
were the 20th at that point or the 30 at
that point but we were able to get
economies of scale because of the
aggregated size of our merch merch base
and instead of keeping those economies
to scale for ourselves we gave them
directly to the merchants we took a
little bit of margin because we want to
make money but we gave so using Shopify
you know to buy a domain using Shopify
to uh to figure out who's going to
process your credit card payments uh in
your Merchant Gateway it became much
better to you to do it through us than
do it on your own and over time that has
turned into things like Shopify payments
and Shopify capital and Shopify shipping
all these big parts of our business
today were built on this
philosophy that we have an unfair
Advantage because these economies of
scale and if we give it to Merchants it
means that Shopify plays an even larger
role in their lives so the three big
growth strategies the first one is you
had referral Partners so you made it
easy for other people to basically work
on the platform and promote your
platform because if if you're a web
agency and people want to store then if
you make it easy for them and maybe they
get some sort of financial incentive to
and they got they got a REV share for it
yeah we gave them a REV share I think at
the time in perpetuity like 20% of
whatever we took they got
which is awesome which for an agency is
a as you probably know like recurring
cash flow is is King yeah and it's on
and what's interesting about it is it's
on a business right so it's not like uh
so basically as long as the as long as
the quote customer continues to sell
stuff you get a REV share basically
Forever on the business which is a great
long-term I mean it's it's an
incentivizing offer so and also these
these agencies are not going to build
their own e-commerce stack right so they
needed someone might as well use Shopify
and I bring this up because a lot of
business owners that I have you know
they're like how do I how do I grow
right and so that's why I wanted to
really zero in on some of these growth
strategies so one is you had referral
Partners you brought in you you were
generous with them uh to the app
developers and to the web stores they
got 20% of the of the of your cut
awesome uh the second one was you you
had a really sexy competition um and so
I I talk about this in terms of like
making offers to to an audience it's
like how can we make it so good people
feel stupid saying no right like and so
for I would say that obviously it worked
I mean I've heard about it we modeled it
at school.com I just made the largest
investment I've made um into a platform
so we saw that and so we have the school
games and so we really looked at a lot
of the stuff that you guys did there um
try to make it fun and um but the the
key point is that you made it fun you
made it competitive you got you got
customers to compete against one another
but they're all winning um and the major
and this was one point I still wanted to
ask so is it um was the New York Times
the only promotion that you did for that
or was there other things that you did
or like was it all word of M like how
did at at this point like uh when we
started this like Tim was just sort of
coming out the 4our work week I think
was in its second edition but he had
this massive audience and part of the
cool part part of the the the the Beauty
and the value of working with Tim was
not just to gave us a great idea we're
like great Tim now you got to help us
tell the world about it also so if we
would have gone to Tim with this idea I
don't know if he would have said yes but
the fact that it was like Tim's we got
Tim to generate an idea for us it was
his idea he felt personally invested in
in fact he's I I've heard him say this
on his on his own show where he'll say
like you know he's one of the
co-founders of the build of business
competition I love that because we
created a a real vested interest in him
to actually make this a success and it
wasn't just New York Times I mean there
was a lot of Articles written about it
but it also it gave us a narrative a
thing that we were able to go around and
talk about it was difficult for me to go
around and talk about I'm a like you
know I'm sh's chap Storyteller it's it's
it's it was difficult for me to go
around and talk about like software Ruby
on Rails or the Simplicity of e-commerce
but it wasn't as difficult for me to go
around and say hey we created this thing
we think we think everyone has you know
Nike convince the world that if you have
a body you're an athlete like mind mind
blown so so brilliant we were trying to
go around and convince the world if you
have ambition you could be an
entrepreneur and so I had now this new
beautiful asset piece of ammunition that
I was able to go around to media and to
the to anyone that would listen to me to
blogs to celebrities and say there's a
thing here we'd love you to talk about
like oh that's kind of cool that was
really helpful and so for the business
owners at home um one big one obviously
was Tim got involved and so if you're
like how do I promote my business
finding a brand Champion or finding
somebody who I mean there's if you've
seen um I think is it is it air that
movie that's uh it tells the story of U
Jordan's like yeah so like sometimes you
need to find like if you like if you
have an audience awesome then you
already know what you're doing but if
you don't have an audience you're more
of a product person and you're like
shoot how do I get this to the World
sometimes finding your Michael Jordan
and in this instance like Tim was
probably the Michael Jordan for that era
for that for entrepreneurship definitely
right for entrepreneurship at that time
um and so being willing to and I'm sure
that Tim had a good deal with Shopify
for you know I'm sure that there was a
deal with him that worked out for sure
that he's profited a lot from um and so
sometimes you just got to be really
generous like the Michael Jordan deals
first if its kind it was who was It was
kind of crazy the the the founder you
know the Phil was like I don't know this
like should I really go all in on this
person and sometimes you got to make
bets right and obviously this bet paid
off the Michael Jordan bet paid off and
so you come up with something really
sexy and then you find somebody who's
the perfect fit for it and then you put
it together right and so just as like
and there's always a perfect fit right
there's always someone out there there's
someone who if if if if you're if you
have a product physical product or space
of software digital product there is
someone out there that has purchased
from you even if you're a small business
who probably has some sort of Leverage
meaning they have an audience they have
a community they have a big newsletter
big following they know a bunch of
people if they have bought your product
organically and they have a connection
to you organically you asking them Point
Blank hey I have this crazy idea you
seem to like my my my tea um and I would
love to feature you in a promotion would
you be interested that is very different
than cold calling them and saying hi I'm
Harley from this Tea Company uh from
Firebelly tea and I'd love you to be a
spokesperson like I think the days by
the way especially go back like to come
to present day for a second the days of
Brad Pit Hawking Colgate or or
toothpaste are over nobody wants these
artificial um connections or
sponsorships when you look at what Jimmy
Mr Beast has done with Feasta BS or Emma
Chamberlain with coffee or you see what
Kim cardashian is doing with with skims
because these are all on Shopify I have
a very deep understanding of these
businesses these are authentic real
products that were built curated
organized by these incredible
celebrities who care so deeply about the
product like so the the days of
artificial sponsorship pay to play thing
I think are over and I think I think
what we did with build a business was
almost like showcase that hey Tim's for
some reason interested in our business
hey Tim how do you think we can grow our
business oh that's a good idea we'll do
the competition but by the way we need
your help for this
competition and it's it was really meta
and I I I just really want to hit on
this because this is what a lot of a lot
of businesses need growth right they've
got a product they're like how do I let
people know about it and obviously you
can you can run ads or if you already
have an audience then you already know
that stuff but if you're like well shoot
how do I do it Scrappy right and so like
making an incentive that gives people a
big reason to say yes right finding a
brand Champion that already has
distribution can can be the unlock
because all of that acquisition is
really just based on the negotiation you
have with that one person and if they
can bring a lot like every you have the
opportunity to make a true win-win and
obviously Shopify want and Tim want and
the main one all of the people who built
stores were the real winners here um and
I'll bet you some of the winners on the
stores also did the exact same strategy
that shop was also doing and so you've
got a tea company and they find Mrs T on
I don't know on Instagram who just loves
tries te's all day it's like if she
really did like the product then she
would be a spokesperson and so just
finding that out okay cool and then the
third one you said um and I want to zero
in on this was it was the econ so you
said growth strategies and you talked
more about the economies of scale was
that just that because that seems a
little bit more product focus and I'm
I'm game for that I just want to make
sure that I I yeah I think on that one I
mean it's product focused but it's also
just simply like business focus my my
ability to go and negotiate with a large
payment Gateway every year got easier
and easier why because I was coming to
them as a much larger Merchant now if
you just take a very simple uh you know
a very simple example 10 individual
Merchants go to negotiate with the
payment Gateway on their own they're all
going to get some rates but if I do it
in aggregate with all 10 my rates are
going to be much much better and I can
literally give those 10 Merchants the
exact same rates you know less maybe you
know a couple basis points that I want
to keep for myself from a profitability
perspective that kept getting bigger it
doesn't mean by the we can talk about
you know shop you know like our our
whole shipping thing because we divested
Shopify shipping uh what's called sfn
Shopify fil Network a couple months ago
B A year ago at this point because there
are sometimes we have got into areas
that were not main quests we sort of
call them side quests that maybe we
shouldn't have done on our own in fact
in the case of shipping we found another
company called flexport um whose main
quest is an endtoend Logistics platform
which is what we were trying to build
oursel and rather than build it oursel
we're like you just do it and that we
can talk a bit about the value of what
what some companies are very very good
at partnership I think shop is one of
those companies if you look at what
we've done with a firm for buy out pay
later or Global e around crossb payments
we've really we pride ourselves to being
a company that is a really good company
to partner with which is very unique in
Tech which is sort of all kind of friend
of Mees yeah and I wanna and I I'm gonna
I'm gonna bring this to the the
brick-and mortar chiropractor like so
just just down to to home base um those
relationships don't need to be these
massive Billion Dollar Deals obviously
they work at scale but you know I think
about I think okay so if I'm a caor what
are all the things that um anybody who's
my customer also gets they might go to
the gym they might like smoothies they
might like uh yoga right they might
other things that are and I think okay
well what if I go to each of those
businesses and say hey with every
smoothie just put a coupon you can slap
it on there for a free adjustment so
they're going to get a free adjustment
and a smooth like you're going to
enhance the value proposition that you
have to your customers at no cost to you
but then I get free leads and so it they
get a win and then I get free customers
or at least a free shot at a customer
yeah and so these Partnerships and and
you know this has been a huge core to
every business that I've built is I mean
I think I've built almost the same
amount of revenue from Partnerships and
affiliate relationships um as I have
just from act you know direct sales and
generating them ourselves because you
are known as like I mean you know you
and I know each other sort of from the
community our our own communities like
you were known as being a good partner
meaning you leave enough on the table so
your partners can make money from it you
know uh doctors actually do this really
really well on their own referral side
meaning if you go to see a doctor and
that doctor can help you great they
they'll they'll they'll work on you if
they can't they'll recommend someone
else if you what I've noticed is that a
lot of them recom like it's almost like
a a closed loop circuit where Dr a if
they can help you always recommends Dr B
who always recommends Dr C and and Dr C
always recommends Dr a and sort of this
I think if you're a chiropractor for
example you if you sort of vend diagram
out meaning you look at your customer
base and you ask them you know where do
you go where do you work out what
clothing do you do you like to wear what
where do you go to get your smoothies
for example you probably have your own
version of that but also the people
hanging out in the Smoothie Bar are also
asking the Smoothie person hey do you
want any good chiropractors and the yoga
instructor is also saying hey I think
you need a chiropractor as well and so
creating your own version of an
affiliate program even if it's not
called an affiliate program it's sort of
your own creation of it actually is
incredibly effective and if you overd
deliver meaning every time the
chiropractor recommends the yoga
instructor uh the you know the yoga
instructor's client comes back and says
man that yoga instructor you recommended
is amazing you should send more clients
to that yoga instructor and so there is
an opportunity to sort of overd deliver
to create even more leverage in this
sort of closed ecosystem of reciprocity
and I'm going to give everyone three
quick tips on this number one if you're
going to create one of these
relationships give them customers first
if you give them customers first they're
way more like send them five people and
then make the call be like hey by the
way I thought maybe it'd make sense if
we did some now they're going to want
more of what you J just gave them and
they're going to be happy to talk second
one is in terms of generosity like if
you know what your cost to acquire a
customer is you should be willing to
give at least that for referral two a
referral partner because like you either
pay Zuck right or you just pay another
small business owner and I can almost
promise you that a referral from a
partner is going to be worth more in LTV
so you still get a a better LTV to C
ratio by going to a stronger Channel
with like a referral partner um and one
little thing that uh lela's really good
at this and she has just drilled it into
me over time which has been helpful for
Partnerships is she says never count the
other guy's money yeah and so just
because you're making someone else a ton
of money like it has nothing like if you
take out how much that person makes and
you just look at your side of the table
make the deal make sense for you if they
make a killing awesome they're going to
be an amazing partner right and so I
just want to underline that for because
some of the mistakes I made early on is
I wanted I saw how much I would make but
I've lost deals because I got too greedy
trying to say well he's gonna make even
more than me and I would encourage you
not to think that way because if
everyone grows such it's such an amazing
reminder so I don't I don't watch sports
I don't really play sports so my Sunday
project this is a little bit weird and
nerdy but I I I have this project it's
called Big Shot it's an archive that I'm
creating of the greatest stories of the
greatest Jewish entrepreneurs of the
last half century and so I'm meeting
these people most of them are in their
80s and 90s and I sit down with them and
I record it I put it on YouTube it's not
a big podcast just it's mostly a
personal project but it's fascinating
and i' I've sat down with people like
Izzy sharp who's the founder of the Four
Seasons hotel or um a guy named Larry
Silverstein who's the owner of the World
Trade Center these were poor kids I mean
these people grew up with nothing zero
um or Fran Weisler who's the queen of
Broadway these are very poor people that
grew up and and and eventually created
you know they're billionaires and
they've created Empires um when you ask
them at 90 years old and so I think Izzy
sharp from the Four Seasons Hotel is 95
years old when you ask these people tell
me one or two things that I don't know
I'm I turned 40 this year so Izzy tell
me something I don't know that I should
at my age almost to the I've done about
12 of these interviews so far with these
like older you know icons and legends on
Titans almost all of them to a te say
make your partners really really rich
now the reason I I bring this up now is
because these are people in their 90 in
their 90s who they got nothing you know
they're not trying to have Swagger
they're not trying to like Flex they're
so on and the reason I love interview
them is because they're so transparent
but to a te every single one of them
from these Titans of industry and real
estate to the the the the queen of
Broadway has always made their Partners
incredibly rich and that is not
something that is intuitive but it's
something that I think like is is
legitimate
I I I love I love this entire line of
thinking because um I mean it goes down
to the just more of abundance mindset
most of the people that I know they were
wealthiest in the world just don't see
business as a zero some game yeah right
it's just like everyone actually can win
whereas in a lot of games it isn't it
isn't structured that way uh whereas
like even just the the build a business
competition you mentioned earlier like
sure there was one winner but do you
think that number two to number 100 in
on the list was like oh man I'm so
bummed that I only got to 100 that's the
craziest part number two number and
number 100 are have built million-dollar
brands also right and that's this idea
of like positive some thinking I think
is so important I know there's like you
know like I'm an optimist I know you
were you were also Alex but one thing
that I think people Miss is often when
you go to raise money for those of you
that are looking to raise money one
criticism you often get from investors
is this concept of Tam total addressed
Market how big is your market and if
effectively what they're trying to say
is that if you look at your Market it's
a pie and your Tam is effectively the
pie and your your your market share is
the slice of the pie I think that's very
flawed thinking and I think if we would
have done that at Shopify we would not
be a hundred billion dollar company our
version was not let's take a piece of
the pie rather let's grow the pie itself
and so um we'll get to the IPO in a
second but we took our company public in
2015 May 2015 on the New York Stock
Exchange it was a billion doll company
at that point so um but you know um 1%
of the market cap that is today at the
time um every when you before you go
public you won this road show we did 93
meetings all over the us and you're
meeting these investors and you're
meeting These funds and you want them to
invest in these big funds that have
trillions of dollars under management
and this idea of Tam would come up over
and over again and I needed to have an
answer for what the Tam was and I
remember it off by heart it was there
were 46 million retail smbs on the
planet I think at the time we had 100
under three 200,000 of them so big big
growth opportunity ironically if you
sort of you know we're now n years past
the IPO if you look at Shopify today a
lot of our customers are not uh just SBS
we have very large companies we're also
well beyond e-commmerce we have tons of
merchants us us for point of sale
physical retail we have t we have a
capital business a payments business
there was no way for them to actually to
for me to give an answer around Tam in
terms of like foreshadowing what we
would become and so I love this idea
that you're talking which is like
positive some thinking and optimism
where share share the wealth of other
people around you because rather than
sort of thinking of the pi as sort of
this finite space think about the pi as
infinite and encourage more people to
participate that's how you build these
like generational hundred-year
multi-billion dollar companies I talked
to a fund manager um the other day and
he was uh and he is a public a public
fund and he was he was saying you know
one of the things that I really like is
that I've got 10,000 people praying that
I win every
night is that great yeah I think Zig
Ziggler said something to the degree of
like you can have whatever you want in
life as long as you have other people
get what they want first um and I I just
I just really really believe that
because I've so I actually feel like
I've actually put some numbers to this
but I think that from an
entrepreneurship perspective it's about
on Tenth and what I mean by that is like
you get to keep about one tenth of the
wealth that you generate for other
people and so I've just seen that from
like the number of entrepreneurs that I
look at like how much the market cap
like not market caps the U like total
revenue that's run through their
platforms versus how much their Equity
stake is and what it's valued at like
the amount of times that I've seen that
equation done where like it's 10x like
you have to make 10 times the amount of
money for other people as you'll be able
to make um it's just been really cool
and I think framing it that way is like
how do I make everyone else a ton of
money
like everyone loves doing business with
someone who makes them money and then
they like and then they will want you to
keep keep doing business with them so 20
our 2023 numbers are not out yet Q4
earnings are coming out soon so can't
talk about that but I'll tell you last
year in 2022 shopify's Revenue was but
$5.6 billion under six billion our
Merchants the people that use Shopify
made almost $200 billion doll in in gmv
and revenue and sales that is I mean
that is amazing I'm very proud of that I
love the fact that our Merchants made
200 and we made 5 point something like
that is the that the reciprocity that I
think is important we I also love the
fact that our our ecosystem Partners
made more than6 billion last year that
matters because it means for 2023
they're going to come back and work with
us again and so I wanna I this is a
really good line of thinking for I think
a lot of the people in the audience so
one is we we've got this big theme of
reciprocity and what are what are some
of the other because I'm I'm skipping
one ahead but I think I think I think
it's worth it so what are some of the
you asked you put this question which is
what are some of the things I don't know
what should which is actually a question
that I ask people too so I I like that
you asked that question what are some of
the other things that came up from those
conversations or just things that you
would share um as some of the big
breakthroughs and like really ones that
you were like I really thought this and
I was dead wrong and I see this now and
it changed everything um all right let
me go uh a little personal for a second
because I I think um these conversations
don't really add as much value unless
you can sort of take off the facade yeah
um I have I turned 40 two months ago my
wife turned 40 a month ago so we've like
been doing a lot of like reflection on
our life and and you know we're grateful
and we love what we do we're doing our
life's work and all that but one of the
things that I really believe on a
personal level is more true to me now
than ever is this idea that
vulnerability is actually this
incredible superpower and my life has
gotten dramatically better when I became
a lot more vulnerable and I'll give you
a quick example um I became I was I was
the chief operating officer of Shopify
between pretty much 2015 or so and 2020
so post IPO until sort of the
pandemic and I loved being shop coo um
it was a big role I had thousands of
thousands of reports and most like
pretty much all the non-engineering
organizations you know rolled up to me
and I I thought that was cool I thought
that was really fun and and and I felt
good about that but I I wasn't I wasn't
happy um I didn't feel necessarily that
I was the best coo in the world um but
there was no way in hell I was ever
going to raise man and say this is not
the right role for me this is not what's
going to keep me at Shopify for a long
time and it was only until I had a
really good chat with Toby and I was
like look I was like um like there is
someone who's better at this role than I
am I'm certain of it and turns out it's
Cass who's our current COO uh he was
initially he was running product for
payments for us our money product but
he's now he he loves being the COO and
running operations the way that I love
storytelling and I never would have had
this new sort of this next gear of of my
career at Shopify
had I not had a little bit of like just
gotten over my own my own my own
crap to say this is really not for me
and I think this idea of of
vulnerability showing weaknesses being
this like weird bravado insecurity thing
I think the more you show vulnerability
the more you ask for help the better
things become and I recognize that it's
easier for someone like me to show
vulnerability at my stage than it would
have been for me to show 10 years ago um
but I actually I I'm as I get older I I
believe that lesson less that I actually
believe it any stage being really honest
with yourself and being honest with the
people around you about what you want to
do what you love doing what you're
really good at like this idea of I've
mentioned the term life's work a couple
times there's a great Japanese term
which is Icky guy which is effectively
like what do you love what does the
world need what can what can you get
paid for that idea of of finding your
thing at at a stage in life which where
you're not 95 like is sharp in Four
Seasons but you're 40 like like like I
am or you're 50 or 60 or 30 I think is a
great gift and I think you're able to
find your thing a lot easier when you
simply are a lot more um vulnerable
about that and and more more than ever I
I really look at that today as as as a
real strength that's the first the
second thing I would say is even uh
Shopify is you know we have I don't know
eight or nine thousand people at the
company Shopify is very much a Founder
Le company but also the people that work
at Shopify have this incredible Founders
mentality they act like an owner with
every expense that they spend um the
Speed and Agility they use um they
reject like best practices quote unquote
they
reject processes that don't make don't
make sense don't make don't make it
faster and not just that we encourage
that if you look at the most like some
of the biggest areas of Shopify They're
ran by founders of companies that we've
Acquired and they've stayed at Shopify
long past the earnout dates because
we've created this sort of crafters and
founders Paradise at this company in in
many ways it is like this this
incredible like um Collective of
Founders and and and entrepreneurs and I
think that you can do that at any stage
of company but if you but if you're not
careful it goes away really quickly and
there are very few companies at our size
today that feels like a founder-led
entrepreneurial everyone calls
themselves the largest startup like it's
it's almost you know it's such a common
thing to say but it's it's most
of them are not like that and I think
one thing that you can do as the founder
of your company is instill this Founders
this Founders mindset or founder
mentality and you can keep it there if
you work at it and I think the results
are almost always unequivocally better
what do you do tactically in order to
keep that so a couple things are very
simple in most companies of our size the
way to to get a promotion is to go into
management there's one track it is and
it's it it always leads to a manager
type role um
we don't do that there are other tracks
that Shopify there is a manager track
there's also an individual contributor
track or we call the crafter track there
are these other tracks that allow you to
stay at our company for a long time and
if your craft is engineering or it's
product or it's sales or it's
storytelling and it's it's sort of brand
building we are absolutely in fact not
even okay with it we are going to be
super happy if your mandate for your
career is to get really really good at
being the world's best marketer or the
world's best sales rep or the world's
best whatever um so one is we've created
these different tracks at Shopify and
we've create which is sort of you know
like the way I like to is like Shi is
really a crafter's paradise that's one
the second thing that is really
important is we also encourage like real
disagreement we invite people to
actively disagree when something just
doesn't feel right um now if like if
we've made the decision we've beat it up
you know dis you know disagree and
commit sometimes has to happen also but
instilling a place where like you
encourage open debate is really I I
think super important I I I think most
companies talk about transparency and
they talk but it's it's it's total
you do any tactics to encourage
that I I just I I always get into the
weeds but like yeah the track makes a
ton of sense like that was like for me
you know with with with our companies
like I will I will that'll probably be
my number one takeaway from just my
tactical takeaway is like interest
having individual contributor tracks
because one of the big issues that a lot
like when you have a star media buyer
right in a company that guy usually
doesn't want to then manage media bu
like he's us like that person and why do
you want that person to like you want
that star media buyer to be a media
buyer and what if that star media buyer
is a seven and actually wants to become
a nine or a 10 at some point now all of
a sudden you have like the world's
greatest media buyer so one thing is I
think you do have to have a conversation
with people um no matter what size your
company is like what track are you on
are you in a manager like there are some
people who are just so great at
management you want them to manage teams
they just they're really good at that
stuff but I think having a conversation
say what track are you on really really
matters the second thing I think that's
also uh that's also really important is
um I know every company want likes to
talk about things like you know
transparency and and open communication
um we write a letter to our board um
every quarter we share that letter with
the board the whole company we and it's
not redacted it's exactly the letter
that even at our size that we share with
the board we share with the entire
company a small now not every letter is
going to be this holy mind-blowing
you know uh piece of content they're
always really interesting um but
sometimes you know it's more like making
sure the trains are are are on time and
stuff like that but what it does do over
time is it it really brings everyone
into the same page of like hey the
things we're telling the board we're
also telling you that there isn't these
like two different versions of The
Narrative of the company and um I think
that's something that is is it's it
seems simple uh but it's really really
impactful especially if you do it really
consistently I'll give a I'll give I'll
give the listeners a tactic that we have
done for this which is um we actually
run open book financials in all of our
companies and so when we do quarterly
it's like here's where we made money
here's where this like we spent money
and it didn't work out well and so
that's helped for everyone feeling like
they're on the same page that we're not
hiding anything and if things are going
really well they can see it and if
something doesn't go as well like some
of the decisions that that happened
downline we're like well that was
suffering and I guess this this does
make sense that we decided to divest in
this kind of endeavor that we were doing
and I know I love suie but I get it you
know like even even if people aren't
like stoked about it like they get it um
so I was just I love this is great by
the way um and so acting like an owner
you you operationalize that um by
creating individual uh contributor
tracks and by having manag tracks really
so people can be honest about what
they're really good at and the one
tidbit I'll give for people who actually
aren't owners or just like uh
entrepreneurs sorry uh employees in
businesses is no one can fault you once
you own your flaws like if you're like
hey I really suck at project management
and if you say that upfront then people
are like they don't they don't talk
behind your back about it they'll just
talk to your face about it because it's
not a secret you're like I know I suck
at project management and so the more
it's like Eminem's whole thing is like
if he claimed every single deficiency
and flaw that he had no one could say
anything back to him in rap battles and
even though you know hopefully Corporate
America is a little bit nicer than a rap
battle maybe it isn't um yeah I it may
not always be but I think you're right
about that I think also the thing that
what what happens is when you say to
someone look I don't want to be
Riverstone I don't want to be
well-rounded I want to be really really
pointy at at this thing and that means
that these other things around me I'm
going to hire or I'm going to find teams
who are really good at those other
things now you're beginning to actually
put yourself in a position where if
you're not like the world's greatest I
don't know writer for example um but
you're really good at like coming up
with like you know great slogans or
you're not the world's great ad you know
you're not great at writing ad copy but
you're a great media buyer now if you
say look I'm not good at ad copy but I'm
I'm so good at finding opportunities for
for great exposure if you say you're not
good at that that means it invites
someone who may be really good at copy
to come and be your like your your your
your your buddy your best your you know
your best friend at work that stuff
really really matters and I I think um I
I think that stuff really is really
great the only other thing I will say is
this um I know a lot of companies talk
about Mission and Northstar one thing
that we are very clear on even from from
from day one till now is um we are a
merchant obsessed and what does that
mean when given any decision whereby we
have to pick one of two things we always
ask ourselves what is better for
merchants now by the way that is
different than let's say Amazon for
example who is very famously consumer
obsessed they don't like that's what
they care about they're very clear about
that when you work at Amazon if there's
like 100,00 people work there they are
consumer obsessed by creating this this
very simple heuristic of which allows
you to say given two opportunities both
seem pretty good how do you actually
evaluate it well what's the one that's
best for the merchant that means that
thousands of people work at Shopify on a
daily basis are making independent
decisions that all roll up to that
centralized Mission which is we are
Merchant obsessed we care first and
foremost about the millions of of
business owners that use Shopify and
again it sounds obvious but most
companies totally toally mess us up and
where the the vision emission stuff gets
really important just for everyone who's
listening is like once you get to about
a 100 employees that's where you're
you're usually two to three levels away
like if you're the founder you're two to
three levels away from people who are
getting hired you're starting to hire
people you don't even know their names
like this is where this really becomes
important because decentralized
decision- making is the only way you can
continue to scale and you need people to
make decisions that would be in align
with align alignment with you like you
can't be in every room to make every
decision and so that's where Mission and
values create decision making Frameworks
that people can use as litmus tests of
okay what would Toby do right now well I
know that Toby says Merchants are North
Star and Merchants would not like this
then we don't do it right even though
we'd make a little bit more they don't
like it and that's what correct I just
want to highlight that because a lot of
the people I mean obviously we take
businesses on um smaller than
Shopify that we invested but like we'll
we'll go through this exercise of
leadership because usually when they're
at you know between 10 to $30 million a
year this is when this gets really
important to get to 100 million year in
revenue and so forth and so like if
you're at that point in your stage like
this gets important I also think
something you're sort of you're sort of
skating or flirting with a little bit
which which has to be said is I think
that there is this strange thing that as
you grow so you mentioned 100 people
there's actually a real thing it's
called it's called dunbar's number it's
150 people right and dunbar's number
basically goes back to like the days of
like when we're all living in tribes
that basically a tribe size should never
go beyond 150 there's some sort of
science around humans can only really
remember 150 people at any one
particular particular time I went
through the 150 Mark a long time ago at
Shopify it does change and there's no
question about it but the one thing that
often happens when you cross that 100
Mark or 150 150 person Mark is you begin
to do this whole like um you know
macromanagement you sort of get out of
the weeds and actually I think this
whole narrative that micromanagement is
bad is total horseshit I actually think
that the best leaders I know whether
they're running like trillion dollar
companies uh because I know some of
those or 100 billion dollar companies or
million dooll companies the best leaders
I know are in the Weeds on the things
that matter most and even you know I'm
preparing now for my earnings call which
in two weeks like I'm In The Weeds on
this like we have an IR team who could
prepare all this no I want to actually
go through every single word in the
script in the press release in the
narrative I want to go like word for
word on my own before anyone even takes
a look at it because it matters so much
and if that's my craft that's what I'm
supposed to be responsible for then I'm
going to be in the weeds that I think
there's like this this Corporate America
you know bashing of micromanagement and
I I think I I I think some
micromanagement is actually really
positive and needed we agree and um we
have a little saying for this internally
which is win in the weeds yeah like
that's like that's where you're GNA go
Toe to Toe with somebody's like you're
going to win in the weeds like that's
how you do it and I like like I feel the
same way if some cor you know some some
president of some other company of our
size uh is not in the Weeds on on on
earnings on on press on part
Partnerships I'm going to run circles
around them because I am in the weeds
because you have the the visceral
knowledge of like the stuff that really
makes it and one of the things that also
helps with this is that if you in the
weeds when something goes wrong you know
why it went wrong and you can make a
pivot where if your two levels removed
you don't know why it didn't work and
then your decision making of what to do
next then relies on secondhand and it
gets really really messy after that you
make really dumb moves um okay so we
have reciprocity is one of the big
driving things we have uh vulnerability
and then the downstream impacts of how
you've kind of implemented that Within
Shopify with the individual tracks um
and encouraging open disagreement among
people and giving everyone kind of a
North star so everyone's aligned with
how we're are like what Frameworks are
we going to disagree around like it's
not whether we're doing customer or
we're doing Merchant the disagreement is
going to be which of these best serves
the merchant if we're going to disagree
correct right so um I want to zoom out
and so I said we're going to look back
and I think we took a little bit of of
final nugget stuff and moved it Forward
which I loved anyways so if we're
looking forward right um you sit in this
really unique perch that I mean maybe 10
people on Earth sit on that you sit on
top of this mountain of data and you
kind of see around the corner and so
what's kind of what's what's what's
what's coming right what are you what
are you thinking about for Shopify um
and just kind of the marketplace overall
for retail entrepreneurs or even just uh
entrepreneurs in general look we talked
a little bit about the sort of idea that
the cost of failure is trending toward
zero it's never going to be zero because
ultimately like it's sort of ASM toop
because ultimately like the you have an
opportunity cost like you could be doing
something else um so it's never going to
be zero but it's getting close to it I
think a couple things around the
entrepreneurship thing one
is I think entrepreneurship now more
than ever before is default Global I
think this idea that we've imported um
physical geographies and borders of
countries in from the physical world
into the digital world is really silly I
don't think I mean you know you see a
lot of great Brands behind me that I'm
very close with I put up uh you know
from kth to Supreme uh to Mom spaghetti
which is M&M's company to Firebelly
which is my little tea side hustle um uh
master and dynamic headphones these are
some of the companies that I love that
I'm connected to none of them have
Geographic limitations that's just not
how they operate I get it it's more
complicated sometimes to sell although
frankly we have a product called Shopify
markets and markets Pro which makes
everything really easy there um but I I
don't want to this isn't a shop pit just
I think one like your total addressable
Market when you're getting started is
anyone on the planet who wants to buy
your particular product first second of
all is I think the idea um if you listen
to any of the earnings calls from these
big um big retailers one of the terms
you often hear is this concept of
Channel conflict which is a very simple
thing it's online is doing well but it's
hurting offline Instagram Commerce is
doing well but it's hurting my online
store I I when I think about the brands
that I admire the most across millions
of stores on Shopify none of them none
of them use the term Channel conflict
why because they are Channel agnostic
what they care about is serving their
customer in the way that their customer
loves to be served or wants to be served
which is very different than pretty much
you know the history of retail where if
you wanted to buy bread you went to the
baker uh in the Town Square you want to
buy shoes you went to The Cobbler down
the streets in the 80s I I'm a you know
I'm an 80s kid um when I went to go buy
a video game I'd have to line up at the
store at this hour doors open wait in
line use this credit card no not that
credit card use this one that whole
thing was the concept of the retailer
dictating the process of purchase to the
consumer is over and the reason that
you're seeing you know things like
shopay for example become so popular is
because seamless simple easy convenient
checkout is what every consumer wants
and so modern retailers today one are
graphically agnostic two our Channel
agnostic they sell across every channel
the reason why you see us do things like
we there's a there's a Spotify channel
for Shopify so if you're an artist most
most merchants on Shopify are not
artists but if you're an artist and you
have your Eminem for example and you
have a great popular artist profile uh
and fan base on Spotify now you can sell
your merch directly from your artist
profile Pat and Spotify won't be
important to most people but our if we
want to qualify and re-qualify to be the
retail operating system for these
millions of stores our responsibility is
every surface area on the planet digital
physical anywhere in between that a
transaction could happen we have to make
that easy so that's probably the second
thing I think that's happening retail
and then the third thing that I think is
is kind of like a an interesting thing
um is that I think business is becoming
it all siiz is personal and you do this
very well Alex maybe better than anyone
but you know your own personal brand and
your business's brand they're not
separate anymore um a couple uh a little
while ago I saw very uh very high-end
brand their online store was down um
I'll say it was Versace Versace went
down I think eight months ago when I
tweeted I said Versace like let me help
you out um and it end up leading to some
of the Versace Brands coming on to
Shopify at that point was I the presid
of Shopify was I Harley the entrepreneur
was I Harley the like human like it I
think this idea that that you know work
life balance or work life Harmony the
separate I think it's I think it's over
I think people I think we as
entrepreneurs and aspiring entrepreneurs
in 2024 we have to sort of incorporate
all these things into our backpack our
businesses our personal life like you
know you talk about uh you talk about
your wife Lea right all all the time
about being part of like you you sort of
mix in between total addressable market
and talking about your wife I do the
same thing like Lindsay my wife is a
huge part of my life and when I go home
I talk about work and I was talk about
our kids and I like I think this there's
sort of this wonderful harmonious
situation now where we don't like we're
not separating these things we're not
waiting to retire to live our life I
think more and more you're able to kind
of like have a personal brand but it's
also your business's brand and you're
also an extension of the company but
you're also your own person and I
actually think that's a wonderful new
thing that new phenomenon um that is
very different than our parents and
grandparents and great-grandparents had
yeah and they don't really get it as I
right I mean Mr Beast is he a YouTuber
or is he a or is he a confectionary
genius with his chalk who cares he's
this amazing guy he's a great
entrepreneur and he makes content and he
makes chocolate and he makes burgers and
he makes cool videos and he's a cool
dude and like who cares how you sort of
categorize these people um and that's
the reason why actually back to what we
said at the beginning authenticity is
going to rule here and if you are if you
are full of people are going to
figure that out very quickly and they're
not going to buy from you and they're
not going to want to participate in your
journey but if you're not full of
and you invite people along into your
journey and you you talk about your kids
and your spouse and your business people
cheer for you and it goes back to what I
think you said you know uh earlier is is
um that that that quote about you know
you want as many people cheering for you
as possible and your journey forgot the
exact quote but if something like that
and um because I I like defining terms a
lot it's like one of my hobbies but
defining it from a behavioral
perspective so a lot of people are like
well what is being authentic or like I
want to be authentic like how do you do
that um the best definition that I that
I have that's working is um behaving as
if you could not be punished and so
oftentimes like we censor ourselves for
fear of punishment we like the many
things that we don't say or don't do
because we're afraid someone's going to
say something or someone's going to do
something reaction and so basically if
you're in an empty room you have almost
no no potential for punishment right and
so it's how you act as if you could not
be punished is how you are authentically
um and so we talk about this concept of
like you the niche so it's like what
isan he likes he likes he likes aliens
he likes you know weird government stuff
he likes uh fighting he likes comedy he
likes biohacking he likes taking crazy
drugs like he likes all sorts of stuff
and so if you're to say hey I want to
start this podcast where I talk about
aliens fighting comedy like all like
people be like you're crazy but it's Joe
Rogan and so it also creates a
one-on-one category that only you can
really occupy and so I I I genuinely do
believe this um that everyone is kind of
unique um in terms of their distinct
interest and kind of like if they were a
chart like how H how the point of their
Rock is in one directions versus a 100
other ones and so I do think there is a
thumb print there that that is unique to
the individual where people do become
rounded Stones is because they pull back
on their pointy bits and so then they do
look more uniform and so people look
uniform but aren't in reality and so
looking at these three big things in
terms of what's coming around the corner
in Commerce and kind of like where the
best brands are indexing number one is
that they see everyone as a potential
customer around the world not not not
not just their local area just even
people who speak their language uh
second was that they don't really care
where the customer comes from like if
more people know about your stuff and
you put it in more places more people
will buy it and as long as you treat
them well you'll make more sales and you
get more rep repeat customers and then
the third one is creating allow
basically allowing yourself to be you
publicly and being more okay with the
association that's going to happen
inevitably with you starting a company
because if you really believe in the
product it's going to be in mesed in
your identity like it's going to be part
of who you are and rather than caging
these things out or boxing them just
leaning into the fact that like you're
you and you own this thing and I think
that what we were saying earlier with
kind of Tim Ferris and these brand
Champions like those other people can
contribute their thumbprints to your
product as well well if you're authentic
then other people that are kind of like
you like you know I I I I like to I like
to be exothermic like I like to take I'm
very high energy always have been um I
like to add energy to other people and
other other situations and rooms and
convers and so I'm just to like I want
to be exothermic and so everything that
I do I want to like I want to be the
exothermic person what that means is
people see me being exothermic mean you
and I sort of connected like you and I
are kind of social media friends like I
was being exothermic and you were being
exothermic we're like hey let's be exic
together that's how you and I that's why
we are talking right now because I try
to be authentically me on the internet
and you try to be authentically you and
the internet and so we connected and
like immed like yeah we kind of like
each other that you get tons of people
coming at you asking to do stuff
together and immediately you're like ah
something is off here and and I I I feel
the same way sometimes when people come
to me and they say like I want to
connect I want to do a deal with you um
when you are exothermic and if you are
or when you are authentic you actually
invite other people that are similarly
authentic in your way into your lives
and you create these amazing communities
and friendships and relationships and
it's it's really fun but you know I mean
it's it's a great sort of place to wrap
up I think which is like there is a deep
optimism I think around the
entrepreneurial community and for those
of you that are listening whether you're
an entrepreneur or aspiring entrepreneur
one of the best parts of
Entrepreneurship is that all of us not
all actually not all most of us didn't
sort of start with like some sort of
like we didn't start on third base most
of us started at the beginning and we've
been building ourselves and so when we
see other people building on their own
whether they're chiropractors or they're
Tech entrepreneurs or they're lawyers or
accountants or they someone who's
creating you know I love my Ember mug I
love the guys at Ember they make these
great coffee mugs at St hot whatever
they are I am rooting for them and
they're rooting for me and that actually
that sort of wonderful like ecosystem
reciproc you go back to that that makes
entrepreneurship a little bit less
lonely and also the greatest tool for
humans to find their own version of
success whatever your version of success
is make a lot of money uh put food on
your table be creative whatever that
version is entrepreneurship is this
amazing vehicle and today it's more
accessible than it's ever been and
there's it's tough not to be optimistic
about
that last
question business advice to Harley 10
years ago you've got one thing you can
tell
him um I think a lot of you know a lot
of people don't know where to start we
kind of talked this a little bit earlier
when we talked about t-shirts but just
find a problem that that you feel
yourself and just solve it um yeah like
it's hard to imagine how to scale and
how big it could become don't even worry
about that but like if there's a hobby
like you know um one of my best friends
is really in is is his name is David
seagull he's founder of David's te this
big tea Empire he sold the company 2016
and he was trying to figure out what to
do and all along the way David was like
coming over to my house and we hanging
out a lot and he's obsessed with tea um
I was like dude like you have a thing
it's tea why aren't you build another
Tea Company and so that's where
Firebelly came from and I love this idea
that like you know the thing that you're
searching for is probably right in front
of you and I I know some people say that
you know you shouldn't commercialize
your hobbies but I'm not sure I'm not
really sure I believe that like if you
have this amazing hobby this amazing
interest this amazing pain point you
feel a lot that's exactly what you
should be working on that's the first
thing the second thing I think is like
you know um I'm this is my 15th year at
shopice I'm 40 years old so more than a
third of my life has been spent at this
incredible company and I if if people if
Toby and the board will have me I'll
stay there as long as I possibly can but
finding someone who um like from a
partnership perspective um someone you
work with
closely I think a lot of people will
start companies and businesses with
people that are just like them people
that they would have been friends with
in high school think it's fun and I get
it um and you know Firebelly for example
Dave and I are both kind of similar with
our little te thing um but actually I
think some of the most impressive things
I've ever seen built were built by
people that probably would not have been
friends in high school again going back
to this idea of like of pointy objects
they're pointy in their own way but
their points are not the same and by
combining their points they kind of
create this like Avengers thing which on
their own they'd be doing cool stuff but
like you know doing it all together uh
means they can build hundred billion
dollar company um so those would be some
of the things I I would say maybe the
only other thing is like you know one
just going back to like life life and
work alt together I one of the most
important uh decisions all of us can
make is finding an incredible incredible
partner um spouse wife husband boyfriend
girlfriend whatever um I think people
underestimate how important that is and
I think I I often refer to to Lindsay uh
at our 40th birthday I said you know
Lindsay is my superpower um that I have
this incredible part and and I I I think
we all not all but I I I know a lot of
people that take for granted um how
important that particular decision is uh
I I think finding a wonderful life
partner for you uh whoever you are um is
just probably the most important
decision you're ever going to make and I
think we all some people think about it
very thoughtfully others sort of do it
half-hazard and I think that's a mistake
71 correlation with your subjective
well-being hell yeah so is that true are
you making that up no no that's 7
correlation with subjective wellbeing
the strength and relationship with your
significant other um with that I feel
like it's a great uh stopping point
thank you so much for giving your time
like just just this is so fun I hope it
was valuable to your to your community
and your listeners I'm I'm a huge fan
I'm part of your community and uh I I
Tred to bring as much insight and and
thoughtfulness as I possibly could um
it's it's an honor Alex for me to be uh
talking to you for I don't know the last
90 minutes it's beyond mutual and on
just behalf of you know MOS Nation thank
you so
much appreciate you